dimanche devant l'ambassade de russie un
cri du coeur de ses résidents vers se
vit
dans la foule certains membres de
l'importante diaspora ukrainienne de
paul sommes
ici valeria est en sécurité mais le
conflit lave est rattrapée
[Musique]
dans ces moments difficiles elle se
console en pensant à la solidarité des
polonais à l'endroit de leur voisin
craignait
pour venir en aide aux militaires
d'ukrainiens de nombreux polonais font
des dons de sang comme ici à varsovie
une campagne de dons encore plus
importante sera organisée dans quelques
jours dans un stade de la capitale
polonaise
je n'irai pas me battre mais je peux les
appuyer de cette manière dit cet homme
qui a déjà attendu deux heures et qui
devra encore patienter avant de faire
son don de sang en pologne l'aide est
aussi humanitaire vêtements nourriture
médicaments depuis quelques jours les
dons s'accumulent près de la frontière
au delà de la gestion de crise il faudra
aussi un appui à plus long terme
notamment auprès des enfants
cette responsable d'un organisme d'aidé
aux réfugiés travaille déjà avec des
écoles de la région de varsovie entre
autres pour embaucher des psychologues
qui parle lui craignait selon elle le
défi est sans précédent
elle s'attend à ce qu'un million et demi
voire deux millions de réfugiés entre en
pologne si le conflit ces tirs tous ne
peuvent pas compter sur de la famille ou
des amis pour les héberger des
résidentes varsovie offre donc aux
réfugiés un toit sous lequel dormir une
chambre est disponible dans
l'appartement de la mère d'agata qui est
présentement à l'extérieur de la ville
pour cette polonaise offrir son aide a
été un réflexe naturel
elle ignore combien de temps la
cohabitation sera nécessaire vu les prix
visibilité de cette guerre agata entend
multiplier les efforts et envisage donné
un coup de main à la frontière
une application qui lui permet aussi de
ne pas être constamment inondés de
nouvelles sur ce conflit qui fait rage
aux portes de son pays si la table 10
hockey radio-canada
parce